vamos a resolver el siguiente ejercicio
dice si los ángulos a b y c mayúscula de
un triángulo están en progresión
aritmética y si a b y c minúsculas
denotan las longitudes de los lados
opuestos
a los ángulos a b y c respectivamente
entonces el valor de la expresión a
entre c seno de 12 mayúscula más se
entre a seno de 2 a mayúscula es muy
bien entonces veamos si podemos
resolverlo seguro vamos a poder porque
somos muy buenos y para poder hacerlo
primero tenemos que dibujar el triángulo
entonces digamos aquí tenemos nuestro
triángulo más o menos así no realmente
no importa verdad podemos hacerlo
arbitrario solo es para darnos cuenta de
que estamos hablando entonces este tiene
ángulos a b y c mayúscula y nos dice que
las longitudes de los lados opuestos
vamos a denotar por ejemplo al lado
opuesto de este ángulo sería este de
aquí
a minúscula al opuesto debe es de
minúscula y al opuesto desees c
minúscula
hacer esto un poco más grande muy bien
entonces lo que nos piden es calcular
esta expresión a partir de los
siguientes los ángulos
abc de este triángulo están en
progresión aritmética y eso qué quiere
decir esencialmente nos dice que a veces
difieren
por el mismo número y son números
consecutivos digamos por ejemplo el 1 el
2 y el 3 verdad estos son números
consecutivos y están en progresión
aritmética porque la diferencia entre
cada uno de ellos es 1 por ejemplo qué
tal si tomamos el 2 4 y 6 otra vez son
consecutivos y la diferencia entre entre
cada uno es 2 por ejemplo también
podríamos poner 10 20 20 y 30 verdad son
consecutivos y además bueno no no son
son sucesivos digamos van en orden y
además la diferencia entre estos son 10
entonces creo que ya tienes muy clara la
idea de que quieren decir con
progresiones aritméticas y nos dicen
esencialmente que los ángulos cumplen
eso
es decir si tú tienes tu ángulo a ok no
sabemos quién sea pero ve va a ser a más
un cierto número n muy bien no sabemos
quién es en eso lo sabemos que están en
progresión aritmética están en
progresión aritmética aunque no sabemos
cuál es la constante por la que difieren
y finalmente se pues es de más la misma
n pero ve es amazon entonces esto nos
queda a más n mas n y esto es
simplemente a más 2 en es muy bien
entonces ya con esto podemos también
sacarle más jugo al problema porque
sabemos que la suma de los ángulos de
interiores de un triángulo suman 180
grados entonces si sumamos éste
y este nos debe dar 180 entonces tenemos
a más a más cn más
2n es igual a 180 bien entonces si
agrupamos aquí tenemos 123 us3 as
n y otras 12 nes
nos dan 3 n muy bien y entonces podemos
dividir de ambos lados entre 3 y del
lado izquierdo nos queda a más n es
igual a 180 entre 3 que son 60 grados
muy bien entonces aquí no me dice mucho
verdad no nos dice mucho que como es
algo como es la n pero hay que recordar
quién es a más en donde se encuentra más
n y si nos ponemos a observar muy bien a
más n se encuentra aquí entonces me está
diciendo la información de que am acm
que es de 60 grados que entonces este
ángulo b es 60 grados muy bien entonces
ahora lo que me está diciendo todo todo
en esencia es que bueno el b vale 60 a
es un número anterior por ejemplo podría
ser 59 y se podría ser un número
posterior 61 o bien podríamos ver son
podría ser 60 anteriormente podría ser
50 y después
o bien podría ser 60 anteriormente 40 y
después 80 ok el detalle es que sea una
progresión aritmética y el de en medio
que es be debe ser 60 entonces vamos a
ver cómo podremos utilizar esto para
resolver el problema y lo que vamos a
hacer es lo siguiente vamos a tomar esta
expresión esta vamos a incluso a
copiarla
en 13 seno de 12
se entre a seno de dos a muy bien
entonces déjenme dejen a corregir esto
porque quiero que éste se vea que es una
minúscula y lo que vamos a tratar de
hacer es cambiar todo esto en términos
de lo que ya sabemos que es b sabemos
que de 60 entonces cuando uno de un seno
de un doble ángulo pues lo primero que
uno trata de hacer pues es ir a buscar
todas las identidades trigonométricas
que tenemos verdad aquí no tenemos ave
entonces tenemos que buscar una forma de
poder expresar o poner todo esto en
términos de b entonces vamos a utilizar
para esto la fórmula del seno del doble
ángulo para este entonces seno de 12 es
dos veces seno de ese coseno de sé muy
bien lo mismo podemos utilizar para este
entonces tenemos dos veces el seno de
coseno de a muy bien y ahora hay que
terminar de poner las constantes por las
cuales estamos multiplicando que aquí es
a sobre c +
sobre y así se están multiplicando
entonces qué otra cosa que otra
herramienta podemos utilizar y realmente
esto lo que nos va a servir es utilizar
la ley de senos y voy a y voy a
escribirla aquí la ley de senos que nos
habla de proporciones de los senos de
los ángulos con sus en lados opuestos
nos dice que el seno de un ángulo a
entre a es igual al seno del ángulo b
sobre el lado de que es igual al seno
del ángulo ce sobre el lado ce esto es
lo que me dice la ley de seno si nos va
a servir porque tenemos por ejemplo seno
de c en 13 y lo podemos convertir en
términos del seno de b muy bien también
vamos a utilizar la ley de cosenos ley
de cosenos la ley de cosenos que nos
dice esencialmente es como el teorema de
pitágoras pero corregido verdad con un
poquito nos dice que se cuadrada es
igual a a cuadrada más b cuadrada y hay
que restarle ésta hay que hacerle la
corrección
2a de verdad por el coseno del ángulo sé
que esto esto nos da el teorema de
pitágoras cuando el triángulo es
rectángulo muy bien entonces lo que
vamos a hacer es lo siguiente vamos a
agrupar 2 a 2
con jose no desee muy bien y si tenemos
eso lo que nos quedaría es multiplicando
a seno de c en 13 y ahí es en donde
vamos a utilizar la ley de senos
entonces esto será 2a coseno dc
ok que multiplica dejen de imponerlo con
blanco que multiplica al seno de c sobre
minúscula
y ahora de este lado hacemos lo mismo
agrupamos 12 con el coseno dea y nos
queda más 12 coseno de a y luego
multiplica a seno de a
seno de a sobre a minúscula y esto lo
hacemos nuevamente porque quiero usar la
ley de senos entonces seno de c en 13 es
seno de entre b entonces podemos dejar
lo mismo dos a ccoo seno de c que
multiplica ahora en vez de ponerse no
deseen 13 ponemos que no debe entre ver
porque son iguales seno de b / b y luego
sumamos 12 coseno de a por seno de a
entre a pero eso es lo mismo que se no
debe y no debe entre b y eso por la ley
de senos entonces esto es bastante
agradable es muy agradable porque el
seno de b si lo conocemos manos de hecho
sabemos que ves 60 grados verdad
entonces su seno
podremos calcularlo así que por ejemplo
aquí de hecho tenemos el mismo factor
podemos factorizar lo y entonces también
lo que hay que observar es que estos
términos se van pareciendo lo que
tenemos en la ley de cosenos verdad
es dos veces algo falta aquí algo por el
coseno de un ángulo entonces vamos a ir
haciendo esto esto es 2a dejó un espacio
para algo que quiero hacer
jose no desee
12 dejó un espacio por el coseno de a y
todo esto es multiplicado por el mismo
el mismo factor que es seno debe sobre b
muy bien ahora tú dirás bueno y por qué
dejaste ese espacio entonces lo que yo
voy a hacer es tratar de agregar cosas
para que se parezca mucho a la ley de
ley de cosenos y esencialmente por
ejemplo si sumamos de ambos lados 2
adecco seno de s tendremos encuadrada +
2 a de coseno dc es igual a a cuadrada
más b cuadrada ahora si restamos e
cuadrada de ambos lados nos quedan 2 a
de coseno de se iguala a cuadrada más b
cuadrada menos se cuadrada muy bien
entonces aquí es en donde yo digo que se
parece mucho a lo que tenemos acá
excepto que nos falta una vez entonces
lo que podremos hacer bueno también aquí
tenemos coseno de ser verdad funciona
muy bien pero acá tenemos coseno de a
entonces lo que podemos hacer es
simplemente invertir el papel
de ahí sé muy bien entonces tendremos si
invertimos el papel de ahí
de ahí se en donde haya ponemos una c
donde haya se ponemos una
y aquí sería se cuadrada más be cuadrada
menos menos a cuadrada muy bien entonces
utilizando esto ya podremos decir bueno
fíjate que al primer sumando le falta la
b y al segundo sumando también a bueno
qué pasa si nosotros multiplicamos todo
por b entonces al distribuirlo al
distribuirlo es multiplicar cada uno de
los sumandos porque esta vez ahora no
puedo multiplicar así tan
arbitrariamente verdad porque no tendría
el mismo resultado
entonces si multiplique por b debo
dividir entre b y entonces dividir entre
veces lo mismo que multiplicar en este
denominador y hasta este momento tenemos
todo bien todo bien porque ahora podemos
utilizar la ley de cosenos en estos dos
suman 2 la ley de cosenos por ejemplo
para para este primer sumando 2 ab
coseno d se me dice que es cuadrada más
de cuadrada menos e cuadrada a cuadrada
más b cuadrada menos se cuadrado para el
segundo para este segundo
podemos utilizar esto que es se cuadrada
más be cuadrada menos cuadrada y todo
esto multiplica hace no debe y ahora
entre deporte que es de cuadrada y ya
casi terminamos si te das cuenta esto es
muy muy agradable porque se simplifica
aquí tenemos a cuadrada y restamos al
cuadrado tenemos menos e cuadrada y se
cuadrada entonces esto simplemente fue
lo siguiente simplemente fue 2 b
cuadrada y luego multiplicamos por el
seno de b / b cuadrada
entonces esto se simplifica todavía más
porque nos queda dos veces el seno de d
y el seno de béjart deberíamos poder
calcularlo porque esto es lo mismo que
dos veces el seno de 60 grados
si no te acuerdas cuál es el seno de 60
grados lo puedes poner en un triángulo
verdad ponemos un triángulo rectángulo
aquí 60 grados ponemos una hipotenusa de
1 porque está en el círculo unitario y
bueno aquí tenemos 30 grados entonces 30
grados nos da que este lado de aquí es
un medio este lado de acá nos tiene que
dar raíz de 3 entre 2 entre 2 si raíz de
3 entre 2 y esto lo puedes deducir por
el teorema de pitágoras verdad entonces
no es no es muy complicado desde todos
modos en los vídeos de trigonometría que
hemos visto bien en las fórmulas que
hemos utilizado y esta forma de calcular
seno de 60 grados pero bueno lo
importante es que el seno de 60 grados
es lado opuesto raíz de 3 entre 2 entre
la hipotenusa que vale 1 entonces esto
simplemente es dos veces por el seno de
60 grados que es raíz de 3 entre 2 y
esto todavía se simplifica más porque
este esto se cancelan y nos queda
de 3 y esto es muy muy muy emocionante
porque un problema que parecía muy
complicado y muy muy espeluznante
resulta que tiene un resultado muy
sencillo como la raíz cuadrada de 3
verdad entonces este problema el valor
de esta expresión es raíz de 3 ahora si
tienes mucha curiosidad de donde obtuve
este problema en realidad fue de un
examen la prueba y tj de 2010 que es un
examen que le hacen a muchos chicos que
están en india para su ingreso a las
universidades de ingeniería y de
ciencias allá de niña espero te haya
gustado mucho este problema a mí la
verdad les confieso me fascinó